most proud of is the hermitcraft s p
Server City build from season 7 over a
year of placing blocks in survival and
with both help and inspiration from the
amazing Minecraft Community it was
finally done you might look at the city
and think that you would not be able to
achieve a build like this but there is a
builder in each and every one of you so
don't be overwhelmed just start
somewhere believe in yourself and step
by step the big picture will emerge but
remember do not neglect the bushes so
whether you enjoy building designing
redstone contraptions maybe even
battling out in Hot PVP action or
embarking on an amazing adventure
Minecraft has something for everyone and
that is what I love about this game so
thank you Minecraft for allowing me to
be a part of this fantastic Journey
enjoy the rest of the show
totally
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this is
no that you could make music with Lego
bricks I didn't
we teamed up with Lego and music artists
look model computer to do just that
foreign
[Music]
ER musician inventor a machine Whisperer
welcome to my place I've been set the
challenge of creating the next
generation of soundtracks for playing
Minecraft and building Lego Minecraft
[Music]
ask me to use
how I don't know but I'm sure we'll find
a way let's press record
foreign
[Music]
so now I've got some sounds that I think
will work
I've got this really nice Minecraft
sample for joy
and when you uh put it all over the top
of each other
[Music]
on my own I'm gonna have to build some
assistance our Lego bricks of course you
stay there for a second I'll be back in
a bit
foreign
a fair few Lego Minecraft bricks I've
built this thing over here no it's not a
treadmill it's actually a musical
instrument you see these pins on here
you program in what you want it to play
and these pins push these levers over
here that play some sounds and then also
over here we have a keyboard that's made
from Lego bricks as well and then don't
forget we've also got the sampler sounds
in here loaded
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now our next group of creators focuses
on mods but not just playing with them
we've got behind the scenes look at the
people who make them
hello foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
then Minecraft the joke
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone my name is Rage Elixir and
I create content about everything
Minecraft for my Survival series role
play food challenges to even mods and by
adding mods to Minecraft I've been able
to create a whole unique experience for
myself such as going to space Oh my God
we're actually taking off
spawning scary mobs okay oh what the
heck is that become the strongest player
ah I'm gonna die I'm gonna burn wait
wait I didn't take any damage at all
taming pet dragons
[Music]
I'm the father and even adding Herobrine
to the game you're just a mod you're
just the mod I'm not scared of you hey
yo
I've even done my fair share of trolling
by adding mods to my friend's Minecraft
server I'm a spawn in 173 this one is
this is the scariest one
now that you've seen what I've been able
to do I encourage you to check out what
other creators have done on YouTube as
well
[Applause]
here backstage for a quick reminder on
this year's mob vote we have the sniffer
the Rascal or the tough Golem which one
will you choose there are three ways to
vote you can go and log on to our server
on Bedrock Edition or vote directly in
the Minecraft launcher and lastly you
can visit minecraft.net and cast your
vote there who will you choose go and
vote now
thanks boo really looking forward to
seeing who wins next up continuing on
our Minecraft Community Journey we're
going to take a look at some maybe a
little bit more intense action than I'm
used to in my slow paced survival world
oh hey everybody I'm Blitz welcome back
to Minecraft dungeons so check this out
I've got my Fighters bindings my
stalwart armor and a little lightning
harp crossbow along with a level love
Medallion today we're gonna be having
some fun attempting to unlock some sort
of unique armor here in the Redstone
mines now this is one of my favorite
levels I love the setting of it but
there is a redstone Golem at the end
who's probably going to be quite
difficult we'll smash a couple
regenerative burning quick weak wow
those are actually really crazy moms all
right the one thing I don't want to do
is get all of the creepers mad at me so
we'll get them on our team and then
hopefully they'll just go blow up their
friends other side oh yeah there it goes
no no no no stay away from me oh
that's an Enderman better break all the
rules of Minecraft and shoot it with the
bow no no no no no no no okay I don't
like this this is bad there he is he's
gone now speaking of the red stone Golem
I believe he's in there all right
there's a redstone Golem he's gonna go
down we're gonna hit him right away with
our oh wow that actually went
oh oh what do we get we got Moon daggers
yes those are fast daggers oh Shockwave
Plus swirling and Radiance that actually
sounds pretty good now let's see how
they go against this guy okay you know
what I totally forgot to change out my
web for my uh trinkets but that's okay
and now what kind of loot do we get from
the loot box please give me something
cool let's get some of that legend or
unique armor ah just regular armor
that's okay though because we still got
some sweet Moon daggers so I hope you
enjoyed that little Adventure today in
Minecraft dungeons if you did like it
let me know and enjoy the rest of
Minecraft live
um
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
hello hello
working phone
number
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
videos on YouTube with my friends for
around a year now and I've Loved using
all the new items from all the new
updates to try and like Escape really
interesting situations you could
definitely say I've been in summer very
tricky situations oh my God these guys
uh they weren't supposed to be here it's
fine it's fine okay even in difficult
situations we can get out of this you're
pretty rude right now and honestly this
is gonna be your end right get it
no I I'm gonna kill you wait why wait
what
okay everyone welcome to fight club I'm
sorry
yes
Goodbye Oh my God
I have a water bucket too you know oh
yeah
[Music]
it's fine
you don't have to bring up money with
you of course I did no you did it bro
yes I see you keep bleeding where are my
diamonds
how are you alive hey everyone we can we
could talk about this right oh my
goodness there's uh there's someone
behind you buddy oh okay run run this is
our chance safely to escape I hope you
guys enjoy Minecraft just as much as I
do even in the challenging moments and I
hope you enjoy the rest of Minecraft
live and all its amazing creators okay
bye-bye foreign
it is so cool to see all of the
different ways that people are playing
Minecraft especially when they're
playing with their friends
hello everyone my name is Gemini Tay I
am a content creator from Newfoundland
Canada I play Minecraft creating videos
and builds within the game that focus on
storytelling and fun I am here today to
tell you all about Minecraft smps as I
am currently a part of two amazing smps
Empires and hermitcraft let me tell you
all about them now before we get started
you may be wondering what is an SMP well
let me show you SMP stands for survival
multiplayer it is when you play
Minecraft survival mode with your
friends this is one of my favorite ways
to enjoy the game let's go take a look
at the smps that I am currently in
welcome to the Empire server each of us
on this server created a character to
play and a base theme to build within we
focus on friendship and storytelling
here creating Empires becoming kings and
queens and sometimes even Wizards we
role play these characters and build up
our bases telling stories as we go we
have had some very fun moments let's log
on to hermitcraft now this is a vanilla
SMP with 25 players online together we
focus on collaboration and creating Mega
projects in vanilla here is our spawn it
started as a simple River but is now
built up to all of our individual Styles
speaking of collaboration earlier this
year I needed an ocean Monument trained
and with Hermits helping Hermits who got
the job done faster together it was a
lot of fun and it allowed me to work on
my megabase where I'm building right
next door to two other Hermits and
that's one of the beautiful things about
smps playing Minecraft with friends is
so important to me I'm so grateful for
all of these friends that I have all
around the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
my name is Paula marine and I'm an
Australian content creator who loves
building and also makes some SMP content
too you may or may not primarily know me
from hermitcraft but I also play
hardcore survival too let's just take a
little bit of a dive into what kind of
Hardcore player I am can I have the food
please I would like the food I go book
and I go book and I get some pork chop
it'll be scary night time better go to
sleep otherwise your guest monsters
jumping you in sleep got all those
zombies coming towards me that guy has a
sword he's pointy aha but he did hello
these explosions oh my gosh look at this
place this is beautiful here's the game
however it is not the spiritual forests
therefore I do not want you well that
sure looks like death doesn't it yeah
yeah
um episode two it is great yep I'm the
crazy cat lady in this world I'm making
with it I'm fearless until I am not
Fearless
place in blocks as I'm home but I'm
thinning
hello got my little first piece is
another ride mine hello
[Music]
as much as hardcore worlds do typically
end up in the loss of a world I do enjoy
restarting worlds anyway give it a go
and experience just how fun it can be
anyway that is enough about me go take a
look at some of my hermitcraft friends
[Music]
hello everyone I'm stress monster 101
and I make content for YouTube and
twitch I'm very lucky to have the
opportunity to play on two gorgeous
servers the first one of course being
hermitcraft where I get to take part in
fun storylines and help to create big
builds absolutely everywhere we build
in-game shops we trade with each other
and of course we prank each other
cookies anyone and the second being
bought Hunters SMP where we all work
together towards reaching the end goal
and that's entering the final ball as a
team we each have to get 25 artifact
pieces from running balls balls are like
mini dungeons with absolutely loads of
loot in them and then to get a chance of
getting an art fat piece we have to
defeat the boss at the end I love
running the vaults with my friends as we
get double the loo which is always a
bonus but it's always a risk because I
ain't great at PVE so if I die then they
die and that would be bad playing
Minecraft together with other people is
so much fun and I absolutely love it
enjoy Minecraft live everyone bye
okay everyone the main show is
approaching which means it's time for me
to say goodbye however before I do go
we're going to take a look back at the
past year of Minecraft of course no look
back would be complete without taking
time to remember technoblade and YouTube
is preparing a wonderful tribute video
to remember him techno blade Never Dies
[Music]
thanks
don't mind me just obliterating the
support player dude technoblade why are
you so good you want more that was
incredible
techno blade Never Dies
[Music]
I think I found the gold Meg this is the
Running Animation
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Minecraft producing Minecraft
Bingo because I'm steal anything yeah
that's terrifying
green light
[Music]
pack we got everything
the glass
[Music]
buildability will be the first world of
Minecraft education Edition focused on
accessibility and building inclusive
spaces
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
survive but thrive
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no I don't get a problem
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
parts of my brain
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome I'm your host and
chief Storyteller of Mojang Studios
Lydia Winters we have an exciting show
for you today packed with all things
Minecraft and you'll hear it directly
from the amazing people making it hang
out with us as we show you our new game
Minecraft Legends see what's going on in
Minecraft dungeons find out about the
next Minecraft update and a lot more if
you love Minecraft you're definitely in
the right place welcome to Minecraft
live 2022.
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm here to talk about what I've
personally decided is the coolest part
of Minecraft live the mob vote as you
may have noticed we've done things a
little differently this year but first
let's take a look at our three mob
choices that you the Minecraft Community
will choose from the one that wins the
vote will be fully developed and added
to Minecraft
first we have the sniffer an ancient mob
that hatched from underwater eggs they
loved plants and confined seeds by
sniffing the ground if you vote for the
sniffer you can revive this mob that was
thought to be extinct and maybe even get
some new plants next up we have the
Rascal this mischievous mild lips
underground and loves playing hide and
seek if you find it three times it will
give you a prize if you vote for the
Rascal you can play hide and seek for
loot in Minecraft and last but certainly
not least is the tough Golem these Stony
mobs can hold items and move around your
base if you vote for the tough Golem you
could set up your own moving art
exhibition okay so you know the mobs now
how do you vote for them we wanted it to
be really easy for everyone to get a
chance to vote this year for the past 24
hours we had an in-game survey that you
could jump into and cast your vote and
it just closed but there are still two
ways you can vote right now and for
about 15 minutes either head straight
into the Minecraft launcher and click
the Minecraft live tab or head to
minecraft.net live and vote there which
mob do you want to see in the game the
sniffer the Rascal or the tough Golem if
you haven't done it yet Go cast your
vote now and be a part of deciding on
the future of Minecraft now let's go to
Lydia Magnus and Kevin to hear all about
our new game Minecraft Legends
Legends hold great power
the Legends we hold Dearest
are legends of Hope of creativity and of
bravery
[Music]
and friendships
that change the world forever
[Music]
this is the legend of a United over
world
thank you
United
by you Minecraft Legends is a brand new
action strategy game from us emojing
studios in partnership with Blackbird
interactive and I'm here with two of my
amazing colleagues hey Magnus Hey Kevin
hello okay before we talk about the game
which I'm really ready to do could you
tell everyone what you do at Mojang I
sure can I'm the creative director at
the game Studio here in Stockholm nice
and Kevin I am the narrative director
for the game studio in Stockholm so
you're going to tell us all about this
amazing game we've all been waiting for
and first I want you to tell everyone
what does it mean to be a legend I think
the best way to start answering that
question is to talk about storytelling
in Minecraft because stories in
Minecraft means something different than
in most games in most games most of the
time it's the the game gives you a story
and then that's the story that you that
you take but in Minecraft it's all about
the stories that you make and so every
time you log on I log on all of our
players log on the stories that you make
to all of our players the stories you
make or the most important stories in
Minecraft so with that understood I
think what it best means to be a legend
when we first announced the game we did
so with a scene of a villager reading a
bedtime story to a villager child I
think we can all understand that feeling
of closing your eyes and hearing an
impossible story that maybe you maybe
isn't all true but you wish it was maybe
parts of it were it's those kind of
legendary what-ifs that we're going to
add in Minecraft Legends for you to put
into your next Minecraft story I really
love that it feels super complex though
you're taking a game so many of us we
know we love we've been playing for a
long time and then you're trying to
interpret it into something new how do
you do it it's it's not easy to make a
game it's never easy but this game
especially like in with the new team
both in turn a little bit when we just
you know learn Minecraft and not only
the game but the whole experience of
Minecraft because it's larger than just
the games and then working together with
blackwork in Blackbird interact active
in Vancouver just getting them into that
Spirit you know Spirit of the connecting
back to original Minecraft you know just
recognize what's going on in the world
and so on connective everybody who read
that and focus on what we want to do
with this game and get the new stuff in
there because we do want a
differentiation between our games as
well but you still want it I mean you're
really bringing the spirit of our
original Minecraft game and the feeling
of you know you're like we're in this
beautiful place it's different than
Minecraft but it's something special
where are we a little familiar still uh
but Welcome to The Well of Fate uh The
Well of Fate is where we start uh our
adventure in Minecraft Legends it's
where you enter the world
um it's really the heart of the
Overworld in this story uh and it's a
place where over the course of the game
you're going to make uh some very
important friends I think we'll talk
about a little bit later we definitely
will I just love how
you know you feel the mindcraftiness of
it right away the spirit of Minecraft
but you're also you're adding so many
new things you come to The Well of fate
and you have you get really awesome
tools I'm stoked about something yeah
when you come to the real estate in the
beginning of the game you will be given
a couple of tools to that kind of gives
you your ability in this world and in
this game and so to begin with you get
the thing called The Flame of creation
well I mean I don't need to know
anything else that's just so cool it's
awesome the flame of creation is kind of
like making it possible for you to build
spawners that can bring new friends into
the world that helps you out second
thing you will be giving is the banner
of courage and that's a banner that you
can wave in the air and that will make
do your friends follow you and then you
can point them in different directions
and tell them to do different tasks for
you and maybe the last last but not
least my favorite the loot and because
you gave it you are given a loot that
you can play and that you know just play
some music and that will bring in the
Allies into the world they love music
and they will help you to gather
materials and build buildings and stuff
in this world cool and everybody's gonna
get to see a lot of that as we play
through and show a lot more of uh
Minecraft Legends than people have seen
before throughout the show we've asked
our creators to send us questions so
they can ask them directly to our team
working on it and you two get the first
one all right nice
Minecraft that's a really good question
that is and uh every good Legend uh
needs some good legendary danger and the
danger in this game uh comes in the form
and the smell a little bit of the
piglets
um for a while now we've thought about
players have thought about what happened
if the nether would come for the
Overworld uh and so even as far back as
when another update for uh vanilla was
being worked on uh we started thinking
about we had zombie piglens in the game
uh what might they have been in a
slightly less icky form so
yeah here's an image for that kind of
like from relatively early stages when
the term periodic cabin is talking about
like how we explore how to you know
change things in the game and like feel
like
if they are now a total zombie State how
can we get them to be at least a
relatively fresh thing like so a
transition over the time here's another
fantastic piece of art from that time
period kind of like this is in our era
where we kind of started to find that
great balance between you know being
super cute but also feeling a little bit
of dangerous it's a really they're
really cool and you actually have added
different hordes so there's different
pigland hordes that are gonna I mean not
be nice basically yeah as a rule yeah no
we have several different words and they
kind of they bring different things to
the game so they look different they
play different and you know I just act
differently so you can get the new
experience each time you encounter a new
one and I mean action strategy what does
that mean in this game
yeah that's it's a bit of a new thing
for us and for many games it's a unique
combination in many ways for me and uh
we make games that we love to play and
we have many people at the office who
likes to play strategy games so
therefore we want to experiment a little
bit with that and but another thing with
Minecraft games we always have a hero
and representation of the player in the
game world so that's super important and
like and when you have a hero you want
that hero to be able to do some stuff
right so that's where the action
combination comes in and so on so you
you can ride around and you can have a
fun time and just you know uh swing your
sword a little bit have some environment
environmental gameplay as we see here
you know we call call those things
jump caps and they're like super cool
just trying to jump jump around swing
your sword a little bit and with your
sword you can defend it against a few
numbers of picking and so on but first
and foremostly we also have a strategy
part where you're actually a commander
in in the game like bringing your
friends to help you fight because you
can't take on the digging threat on your
own that's awesome and you have friends
that you know are fighting alongside of
you we have some friends that guide you
but you also have just a lot of pure
cuteness yes there is uh well the
Overworld in Legends is a very peaceful
cozy place you can kind of look around
us and see and uh yeah so there's a lot
of mobs who will show up and be very
curious uh about the hero there's a
little turtle following the hero there
uh some of the mobs will be familiar to
players of Minecraft already but there
will be some new little faces in there
as well and like I said most of these
creatures will be curious and we'll
follow you around and and start to learn
about you but some of them may help out
a little bit for example our friend the
Llama uh turns out llamas really don't
like Piglet and you know what happens if
you make a llama mad good okay so we'll
take them only the llamas with us maybe
and you've added friends that Kevin you
talked about earlier that we would we
would talk more about it you're you
added friends that really guide you in
the game which is so cool and very
unique to Minecraft Legends yeah this is
new for uh four Legends and the the kind
of gameplay that we have here because
the uh well normally when you play
Minecraft you show up and and the world
is open to you and there's really not a
lot of immediate pressure uh in Legends
however the piglets have terrible
manners uh they're not going to give you
any time so but I want to just hang out
in the with the bounce caps and the cute
there will be some time there but in the
meantime Pig ones yeah so yeah so uh as
soon as you arrive in the world
um at the will of Fate like I said you
will meet some friends called the hosts
uh and the hosts are interesting
characters uh that you'll get to know
across the course of the game uh and on
screen there's a shot of them is on the
left the tall one is foresight on the
right the little one is knowledge and
the middle is uh action and foresight
knowledge and action are the
characteristics when we started thinking
about these characters that we think all
Minecraft players we all demonstrate
every time we play Minecraft is we see a
hill and foresight is coming up with a
dream of what might be up there uh
knowledge is the understanding of the
crafting recipes and the ingredients
that you need to make that real and then
action is the oomph it's the hard work
to make that a reality so foresight
knowledge in action will help you across
the course of the game
um and hopefully become your friends I
really love that and Yen's actually
headed into Legends to meet up with the
hosts so that you can all get to know
them more
[Music]
welcome back yens
what can I do for you today you're
always a helpful foresight we've been
friends for a while and I felt it was
time to return the favor
thank you anything I can do to help you
with that
your timing is perfect let us hope your
courage is as well come action waits for
us through the portal
action action action where are you oh
hello nice nice little kitten hello oh
action it's good to see you I'm glad
you're back we really need help
protecting the Overworld do you know
anything about that maybe a finger or
two good somebody has to help us put an
end to this
I appreciate the world of confidence but
we might need a few more reinforcements
[Music]
the piglens are moving faster than we
thought we need more time knowledge what
should we do
right now we run
right
huh
surprise
[Music]
oh yes it's a brave dance she was really
Brave yep uh oh my red skies that means
more piglets that means it's time for us
to actually jump into the game we have
four amazing people ready to play from
our team at Mojang Studios hi Anna hi
telemarcus
and from our friends at Blackbird
interactive Haley and hi Pete hello Pete
we're gonna start exploring with you so
let's jump in let's do it oh come on who
is that cool cool animal so this here is
the Regal tiger it's one of the many new
Mobs that you'll see in Minecraft
Legends and it's one of the few that
you'll be able to be able to ride that's
so cool and throughout the game you're
always riding on one and this one looks
really fast yeah that's right that's
right that's one of the reasons why it's
my favorite and also because it's so
adorable it is a really adorables where
are we gonna go uh well I got a couple
things planned where we should be
heading over to help the rest of the
team battle the pigland base but there
was a few things that I wanted to show
off first
I see the wall of fame yeah you sure do
so this is The Well of Fate as you
mentioned it is the player's home away
from home when they're in the world of
Legends it's where you start the
adventure and you return here many times
throughout the course of the game so
you'll become very familiar with it by
the end it's so beautiful I love how
peaceful and nice it is here yeah that's
the idea so actually here I'm gonna
scoop up some friends so you're using
the banner of Courage that's right you
just wave it around whenever there's a
friendly mob nearby and they'll follow
you around
so we're gonna get uh get a group of
animals going here nice quite a quite a
bunch of cuties yeah that's right we're
gonna take him for a swim just for fun
okay so they're coming with you for fun
but not to fight that's right I mean
look at that Pig's face would you send
that face into battle no definitely not
I don't think so I would protect it
though I'm ready so I had a couple more
things I wanted to show first off with
the elaze I'm gonna have still delays to
gather this tree for me that's really
cool yeah you can see him tearing down
that tree
um players will be familiar with uh
vanilla Minecraft uh breaking down the
world and rebuilding it block by Block
in Legends we like to say that you do
that thought by thought the player just
has to say you know what I need some
wood and then you ask the ladies to
gather it for you and off they go that's
so amazing so they will stay there and
just keep Gathering as you go about your
journey that's right you can you can
send them off to gather resources while
you do more important things they're
really nice friends they sure are they
sure are
so right over here is the next thing I
wanted to show off this is very similar
to the bounce caps that you and Magnus
were talking about these sparkling
bushes in front of me are called speed
wheat now the player just needs to touch
these and they'll get a speed boost so
we're going to use these here to rip
through a few biomes and head over to
the team battling the piglets nice off
we go wow we're really fast now oh yeah
that's right
so we're heading into the jungle here
we're gonna hit some more speed wheat
and then we're gonna hit these bounce
caps here so we're gonna be super fast
and jump super high oh maybe we'll maybe
some of our Little Cuties will catch up
but we'll we'll see him yeah yeah we
might be too fast and too jumpy for them
yeah we're not making it easy on them
but um I have faith that they'll be able
to keep up whoa this is gorgeous
yeah this is one of my favorite biomes
it's um partially because of how much
fun it is to run across the Treetops
like I'm doing here but also just
because of how nice it looks oh it's
beautiful and the mangroves are there
yeah that's right so I wanted to show
off this nice bird's eye view here we go
of the Jungle you can see all the
beautiful trees and stuff and the world
is randomly generated so it's always
going to be a bit different that's right
everyone's world will be different the
world is is just like it is in vanilla
Minecraft where you know from one player
to the next the world is generated
differently so it makes the experience
unique very minecrafty yeah we're gonna
head over to the Badlands next but I've
spotted something down on the forest
floor that I want to show off first so
I'll head over here
and this this is the second thing that
the leas do for you this is in the lay
chest and essentially the Lays will keep
these stocked with resources so you can
find them in the world crack them open
see what's inside there we go I got 107
Diamond thank you elaze that's right
yeah so as you're exploring the world
and you find those uh chests around be
sure to open them up because delays
always have gifts for you
oh some of my friends managed to keep up
that's great good job oh hello little
demo you should come with me here we are
in the Badlands so this is the second
biome I wanted to show off
definitely not as friendly as the
beautiful jungle yeah yeah this one's a
little bit more hazardous we've got some
red Thorns over here be sure not to walk
into those those can deal damage there's
a lot less trees there's a lot less Wood
resource in this biome so you have to
keep that in mind when you're when
you're planning planning ahead
oh it sure doesn't this this here is the
pigland base now you can see the portal
over there and then the corruption that
is spread throughout the world from that
portal and that's why we're here to stop
it we got to destroy that portal so that
this corruption doesn't spread any
further
okay now this is the last thing that I
wanted to show the delays can do I'm
going to switch my hop bar here and I'm
going to get get the delays to build me
a bridge across this River
one click and off they go wow the blue
laser gatherers and then the yellow ones
are building things that's exactly right
but then they're both filling chests of
Awesomeness I mean they are really great
yeah they sure are
so I'm actually gonna drop these friends
off here I don't want to bring them into
battle I don't want them to get hurt
yeah I'll be back for you later
okay next is the spawners so here we are
we've got a few of them these are player
built structures and there's one for
each type of mob and essentially you
build them you get your lace to build
them and then you interact with them to
spawn some mobs so this is a creeper
spawner we're gonna spawn ourselves a
couple of creepers I would say I've
never been happy to spawn creepers but
maybe today is the first time yeah
that's for sure you know we're all we're
all aware of how dangerous they can be
but when you use them against the
piglens they're extremely effective and
these are some new Mobs which I love
that's right these are the grindstone
Golems so I'll grab a few of those and
then next I'm going to get a couple of
the plank golems and the strategy really
comes in when you're deciding which mobs
should be fighting the pigwin hordes
because you're doing it in different
ways that's exactly right so what the
player is going to do is they're going
to come and check out the pigland base
much like this see what sort of pigland
units and pigland structures in the base
and then pick their mobs accordingly I
see a lot of action so we're gonna head
out over to Lee and go like in the
middle of battle we sure are
okay here we go
yeah Lee's riding across that bridge
there she's got a whole bunch of mobs
with her she's gonna send them into
battle using the banner of Courage
so that's a big piglet over there is a
lava launcher that is one of the most
dangerous pigments you can find in the
horde of the Spore this is a horde of
the sport base
and uh that piglet you really gotta
watch out for those they can attack long
range by shooting magma Cubes at you
they can also do short range stomp
attacks to destroy any mobs nearby and
Leah's actually put her uh Elise to to
work helping out building those Towers
that's right it's really cool to
actually have more defense that's right
the towers that she's got on the left
and right side of the bridge here those
are Arrow Towers they're gonna shoot
arrows at any pigwens nearby so
um what we're doing here is we're
essentially moving our way into the base
taking out the pickling structures
setting up structures of our own
battling the pig Limbs and making a safe
path towards the portal in order to take
it out so send in a few more mobs in
here on the
um Lava launcher to try and take it out
before we move in on the portal now
Lee's been being handed off to mobs from
one of her other players from Anna and
that's a key part of the play in the
game in my in Legends you have to make
sure to use teamwork everyone working
together against the piglets
oh that lava launcher looks like it's in
trouble
it's in big trouble yeah it doesn't have
much time left
oh there it goes lava launcher down
okay do you think we can take out this
portal oh I know we can
we have a secret weapon
here we go there's our secret weapon
yeah
with the first of stones see this giant
mob behind him scooping up a boulder
he's swinging it into the portal that's
the first one the health bar is already
down so quick yeah these piglings didn't
know what hit him game over
13 a couple more shots
great job team
okay so I'm gonna ask this on behalf of
myself and everyone else when can we
play yeah that's the thing I get that
question all the time my daughter my and
my boys
yeah and I'm happy to tell you today
that it's spring 2023 so that must be
very very I mean you've been working on
this a long time so
I know we all can't wait to see the
community playing yep absolutely and
we're very excited for you all to play
in Spring 2023 and for the first time
ever here's the beginning of our game
the opening cinematic of Minecraft
Legends
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
uh
haha
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
says that I'm winning
um I find that a bit surprising
considering this is like a Cooperative
game also we're live
the Marvel for 2022 is now closed I hope
you got a chance to choose your favorite
mob I know I did yes what'd you think
about the mava this year oh I I thought
it was amazing like oh the team came up
with three really adorable mobs and I'm
very excited to see which one the
community has picked for us yeah it's uh
always an exciting thing and there's
still so much work to be done on the mob
that wins yeah yeah absolutely like when
you see the when the mob gets into the
game that's when you start really
nailing down the details and you kind of
figure out how how does this more
interact with all the other mechanics in
the game and what do we need to make it
like a real a really good mob the like
everyone on the team really loves
Minecraft and wants to make the best mob
possible so now I'm sure they're very
excited to see which one it takes to win
I think we all are since I have you here
we have a Creator question just for you
[Music]
Minecraft
that's a really good question
and a Magnus and Kevin they were talking
a little bit about this because you see
in Legends uh we have their lace and
their lace were created in four Legends
to solve a problem like how can the
player build and collect resources while
focusing on the big picture of the
strategy
um but when we thought about the lace we
thought about and also like what what do
they mean for the bigger Minecraft
mythology if we would call it that and
what would it mean for for the vanilla
experience yeah
um so
uh we uh we we
thought about a lot about it and
included in the last year's uh Mob vote
and and thankfully the community voted
for that one but of course then we
needed to make sure that they worked
well for for Minecraft uh and uh like
that kind of gameplay we had some some
things were of course like the way it
looks and that it loves new music that
was like part of its Essence but uh it
needed to work well for Minecraft and
similarly like Kevin mentioned like with
the piglens uh that like we wanted to
make sure that aliens work well in
vanilla so that that is kind of how we
think about many mobs in all our games
and
they may or may not move to other games
but it has we have to it has to fit like
it has to have an opportunity
essentially and uh obviously in Bank of
Legends it's a legend and many of those
really special ones will probably remain
a legend that's cool so yes
I have a really important question for
you haven't you ever wished you could
just develop your own mob for Minecraft
well I I anyway
now you can do just that
[Music]
The Entity wizard tool is a tool that is
built with our friend Giannis on
blockbench and allows for a simple way
to quickly make an entity and get it
into the game fast
accessible and easy for anyone to get
started with you're not really guessing
as to what a mob does you can actually
just take that as an archetype and say I
want this to be like a bear and then
just build off of a bear it makes it
very easy
the main purpose of that tool is to make
it super easy and it walks you through
all the steps it tells you like it
suggests things that you can pick from
it gives you templates to pick from and
then I think from there you can just
start creating your own Mall from a
scratchy
I think all of us really really want to
see our own mobs in the game like we're
going to kind of dream about having this
new animal or this new creature or maybe
there was a mob vote that didn't go our
way hashtag team copper Gollum this tool
allows for anyone who has an idea to
kind of Express that and put it in the
game and try it out themselves and see
what it would be like
my favorite bird is hornbill toucan so I
really wanted to say like can I actually
remake A hornbill toucan and I want to
build it on the parrot because that gave
me all of the gameplay features that I
wanted and it would make it easier to
make it look like that as well so
knowing both what you want it to play
and feel like and what it looks like
combining those two together really
leaves you in the right place to start
if you're a Scrabble like iOS you can
just start by painting an existing mop
that's one of the cooler things of the
entity wizard you can just paste it on a
map that already exists and then if
you're comfortable with painting then
work on changing the model itself so
changing the dimensions changing the
shape around it get that in the game I
hope you find some resource to get you
started here whether it's our tutorials
whether it's blockbench tutorials
whether it's a YouTuber that's made a
video on this stuff see what other
people are doing out there get inspired
download this tool and just start seeing
what your creativity can bring and try
it out
banana
this one's actually going to be really
difficult how do you make a curved
object in Minecraft how does that work
but I think I've actually done okay it's
gonna need some eyes or something do
reckon we could make like a face just to
make it a little bit more interesting
we do that and then okay that actually
looks kind of cool I thought it was
going to be massive you do anything do
oh you walk okay this looks like an
Adventure Time character I'd always
dreamed to be able to make my own stuff
in Minecraft and now I can
[Music]
we can't wait to see all the cool mobs
you all make I'm not saying I'm still
holding out hope that my owl Lotto from
last year will go in the game but I
definitely am the coolest thing is that
these are the same tools our developers
and Marketplace creators are using to
create new things in the game Minecraft
Marketplace is full of fun content you
can't get anywhere else and today we
have a first look at something many of
us have been waiting for
oh hi there Minecraft family my name is
Jim Lee I'm the publisher and chief
creative officer of DC Comics I'm here
to announce that we are bringing Batman
to Minecraft in a brand new DLC World
launching very soon in this DLC you'll
use Batman's gadgets to explore Gotham
and take on villains like Harlequin
penguin and more as you unravel Joker's
nefarious plot
to celebrate the release of the
Minecraft Batman DLC you can get the
free Batman cap in the dressing room
right after Minecraft live
I know I know you want to hear more well
then check out this amazing trailer for
the Minecraft Batman DLC right now
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I know a lot of the community know you
but for those who don't could you tell
them what you do it oh thank you
hello everyone lovely to meet you I'm
Agnes and I'm the game director for
Minecraft and Agnes later in the show
you're going to tell us about the next
update oh yes so we will show you some
lovely new things and we will actually
do it in a bit of a different way this
year because it's important for us to
learn from previous years
I cannot wait I'm very excited I know a
lot of us are but first I wanted to know
have you ever wished that there was an
opera for the warden yes all the time oh
yeah it's like my biggest Dream well
Element Animation has made your dreams
come true
see
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and it can find you with one sniff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ers
come down to the dark
okay the votes have been tallied and
it's time to hey what's going on Tiny
boost doing what
yes I can't believe it worked
that average sized Foo always gets the
glory but it's finally me tiny voo who
gets to shine the first round of the mob
vote has been tallied and now I will
tell you whether it's the sniffer the
Rascal or tough Golem that's been voted
out okay here it is my big moment drum
roll please
not today tinyvoo you have voted and we
have counted and wow so many of you
joined the vote this year over three and
a half million Minecrafters from around
the world well out of the sniffer the
Rascal and the tough Golem the mob with
the least number of votes is the tough
Golem goodbye little tough Gollum you
will live on in our memories but the
exciting part is still to come towards
the end of the show we will reveal the
winner of the mob vote the Victor who
will be added to the game in a future
update are you excited there's still
hope for the mob I voted for so I'm very
excited
have you ever played Minecraft and
wondered what were they thinking
[Music]
check out our YouTube channel to find
out if you really want to open that door
[Music]
you can also ask specific questions and
we'll answer them we really had to
figure out how to make it look smoother
that's how the LA works I've seen how it
looks and I think it actually looks
really really good as a screaming goat
stay up to date on what's coming up
[Music]
or hang out with us as we play games and
dive deeper into everything we reveal
during Minecraft live
is there something behind the far left
people usually ask me what type of
Minecraft are you and I don't know what
to answer I'm just a Minecraft
step into our world and subscribe to our
YouTube channel
[Music]
we are Overjoyed to see that now over 10
million of you have subscribed to our
YouTube channel thank you to all of you
who watch and enjoy the content we make
it's because of you that we get to keep
making awesome Minecraft videos now
let's talk about Minecraft dungeons and
for that I will of course invite Lord
quite the entrance jealous huh a little
bit anyway when you're not being rolled
around on Thrones can you tell everyone
what do you do at Mojang Studios
I get rolled around and I am also a lead
designer for Minecraft dungeons which
means that I get to contribute a lot to
the creative work in the game which is
amazing that's so cool and Minecraft
dungeons has been on quite a journey the
past few years yes it's been a crazy
ride since launch and we've released so
many things so I thought we could begin
by watching a bit of a recap of the game
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so much great stuff has already happened
it's been so much and we it's been so
great but I think now that we've looked
at the past a little bit we are ready to
talk a bit about the future I think
everyone wants to hear that yes and the
amazing thing is that now we're ready to
announce that we're releasing seasonal
Adventures 3 which is called the phone
Affair and it is All About Pets and new
animals to come to the universe of
Minecraft and here you can see we we
started with some concept art and we
have some authors and ferrets some
penguins and my personal favorite which
is the Hedgehog I see why yes and it's
tiny and it rolls around and it follows
you through the level so yeah it is my
favorite but the final art of the mobs
turn out so good I think the Penguins
feel very well in Camp and we also have
chickens and the clock shroom from
Minecraft Earth and yeah tons of cows
even and The Woolly cow yes our emo cow
we're very happy about it and it's so
cozy but the whole season will revolve
About Pets so all the rewards you'll be
able to get through the season are
around pets so you'll get like cow and
turtle caves and all the emotes are
gonna be about animals so you will be
able to pet your pets or you know be a
bit of a chicken or a bit of a dog why
not that's perfect and also very flashy
flares like the the cat one and yeah all
sorts of cool animations that you'll be
able to get that's all really exciting
but you also get to talk about a new
Mission that's right that's right
Treetop tangle is our mission set in the
jungle biome uh and we're very happy
because we are releasing this one for
free which means that all the players
that never got to play in the jungle DLC
before will get to explore the jungle
that's so cool and it's this massive
tree and you run around in the branches
and inside of the tree itself so I think
it is a very different experience is
such a vertical level yeah I love that
you always feel you can feel that you're
way up high yes and uh I think we should
also talk about my favorite things your
favorite uh it was a bit of my baby but
in dungeons you've never gotten the
ability to replace your enchantments you
know how you get a piece of gear and
they come with their enchantments
and we're finally releasing the enchant
Smith which is a new Merchant that will
move into your camps so cool yes and it
will allow you to reroll your
enchantments if you will okay I think
everyone's going to be excited about
that because I know I have been waiting
for something like that it's great to be
able to change these enchantments yes
but we have a Creator question just
about that let's watch it
hi there my name is Steph saniati I'm
also a
Creator my partner and I love playing
Minecraft dungeons together but we've
always wanted a way to change up our
enchantments I heard in the new update
there might be a way to do that with the
enchantment can you tell us more about
that and how it's going to work
yeah I guess I can give a few more
details let's see so you'll be able to
save the enhancement in high block calls
and after that they'll move into your
camp and you'll be able to go up to
their booth and select a piece of gear
you want to re-enchant select an
enchantment you already had pay a better
goal and the intense myth will re-roll
it just for a little bit of gold I mean
you have to pay them for their work yes
yes yes it is their job yes and I think
I say it's the best thing for last okay
so you know last year we talked about
the tower which was a new feature and it
is that space where you go floor by
floor defeating waves of mobs and you
get stronger as you go and at the end
you get an amazing reward
well we're ready to announce that we are
releasing a multiplayer mode that's
awesome yes and today we have here with
us Kelsey and JP from The Dungeons team
hello
isn't that my throne it is my Throne now
okay let's just get into the game yes
and here they are playing together and
together with the tower multiplayer
we're also releasing new biomes in the
tower so this is set in the end and this
is a demo I balance myself and I made
this level a bit easier for them okay so
so I think they should have a good time
in this floor they they did quick work
there yes and as you can see uh Kelsey
and JP are playing in couch Co-op but
you'll also be able to play this in
online multiplayer and you'll be able to
play with up to four friends uh so yeah
same as as in the rest of the game like
whenever somebody joins or somebody
leaves the game will adapt to how many
you are and and balance its difficulty
uh so we're very happy of how smooth
that turned out yeah and I see these two
uh doing really well here yes it is you
know I I wanted to give them a bit of a
[Laughter]
we want to try to keep the Whimsical
like Vive of the Tower so we thought the
end biomes were very good for that and
oh here you can see like when you choose
a new piece of gear in the tower you'll
be able to see what your friends are
choosing also okay which means that you
can strategize with each other so oh you
choose the hammer I'll choose the
crossbow and then you know you get that
melee strength and I get the range
strength so then you work well together
yes I made this level harder okay so to
give them a bit of a challenge and we'll
see how that goes I think oh I think
it's already looking a little bit tough
yeah but here you can see like how you
collaborate with each other like you put
the totem of healing and then you can
all heal it exactly and then you you
both get it and you can protect yourself
so I think I really really like this
strategy that it brings to the table to
be able to play multiplayers such a
different experience and oh you might
have done this one a bit too yeah maybe
you were a little mean on that but they
did a great job I mean I need to show
the challenge you definitely showed the
challenge so everyone will want to know
when do we get this very very soon uh
seasonal Adventure 3 is coming on the
19th of October oh wow so super soon
you'll get the enchantment Treetop
tangle Tower multiplayer all of it that
is awesome yes but there's also one
other thing that is coming on October
the 26th of October to be precise and
that's the Spooky Fest which is now a
tradition in the dungeons world and this
year you're getting more rewards than
ever before you're getting six pieces of
gear uh and I'm super happy how they
turn out they look so pretty and you'll
also be able to get those pieces of gear
in Minecraft Bedrock Edition which means
that you'll be able to get spooky all
around that is great well you've shared
so much thank you so much Lala I mean
it's oh
oh
[Music]
well as usual the Minecraft dungeons
news was fun and exciting now let's take
a look at something on the inspirational
side
now more than ever the world needs more
hope curiosity and peace
bringing the real world into the
Minecraft world enables us to explore
places we've never been
dig into real issues in an accessible
way and immerse ourselves in history to
shape a better future
[Music]
Experience Life Through The Eyes of
animals living in some of the coldest
habitats on Earth
hunt in a whale pod build the Cozy Nest
protect your Cubs all while learning
about the waste climate change is
impacting these Frozen worlds these five
Minecraft maps are inspired by stories
from the Frozen Planet 2 Series created
in partnership with BBC Earth
head to warmer climates to explore
swamps of mangroves and incredible super
tree species found in 114 countries
join the mangrove restoration project
and use seed cannons to restore these
essential mangroves in a world
struggling from climate change
they're called climate superheroes
because of their innate ability to
sequester carbon don't miss the chance
to learn about these ridiculously cool
trees
[Music]
in Latin explorers Journey with leaders
in the community as you help them solve
tough challenges meet ordinary people
doing extraordinary things like
preserving butterflies delivering
medical supplies and creating murals to
speak out against Injustice this world
was created in partnership with the
Hispanic Heritage Foundation to help
young people build leadership skills and
Inspire local action
[Music]
learn from history with peace Builders a
series of Adventures created with a
Noble Peace Center and games for change
meet Four Noble Peace Prize laureates
and help them avoid and solve conflict
learning the skills needed to craft
peace
clear landmines to save a Cambodian
Village
protest the unjust apartheid system
support refugees after an earthquake we
can all help create more peace
all of these amazing worlds are
available for free in the Minecraft
Marketplace
together we can build a better world
it makes me so happy whenever I see all
of those worlds great it's beautiful and
inspiring and actually I think for us
it's not only like beautiful that we
really try to make the real world a
better place I even think it's the
responsibility because we are lucky to
have so many players and that means that
we have quite a lot of impact and that
needs to come with a lot of
responsibility too and that's the cool
thing because to me it's you know it's
not us doing something by ourselves as a
company it's always with our community
and like the best ideas come from the
community and so many people that love
love the game the way we do yes it's
super inspiring so Agnes you're gonna
tell us the next update I will soon
but first I would actually love to take
some time to talk about what we have
learned from previous years because we
have announced some features that we
didn't manage to deliver and it's
important that we learn from that and
that we take action from that
so for example this year we will only
show features that have come very very
far in the development process because
like with Minecraft live we want to
celebrate this like lovely game together
with our amazing community and we want
to create player dreams so when we show
new things we want like to inspire the
players and I remember for myself like a
long time ago before I worked here I
used to watch mine cons and and I
remember seeing new things I'm like ah I
want to build this thing with this block
I want to go on this adventure and we
want to give these kind of dreams to our
players and then it's so important that
we feel 100 confident that we really can
deliver on these dreams yeah and I mean
it feels like we would tell everything
at Minecraft live and then you had to
just keep up with that you you couldn't
add anything or kind of change things
yes so like in recent years we showed
like the full update almost and then we
were just chasing it for the rest of the
development process and it well it
caused stress so this year we think we
will have time to really like iterate on
the features together with the community
of course and also to add features that
we haven't showed yet like that we
haven't showed today because like we
know we already have so many ideas and
also during the development process both
us and the community so many ideas gonna
pop up and those are also often very
very Charming so we're happy that we
will have like more time to really
explore this update together yeah I love
it let's the team be more creative it
lets us be creative with the community
and like kind of see where the path
takes us and also it's really exciting
to get to hear new things like
throughout the year too so I'm excited
to check what's happening what's
happening but
what can you tell us about the update I
mean I can tell quite many things but
actually first I want to tell you that
we have decided to not name it yet
so for now we will call it the 120
update and it will be released in 2023
and the reason for that is that we want
to shape it like throughout the
development process together with the
community because
like Minecraft it's some kind of like
magic almost to Minecraft and I think
one of the key things that create this
magic is that Minecraft is community
fueled absolutely yes we both came from
the community before so so let's name it
when we all feel ready to do that but
you do have a theme so like some some
things to think about we do know what we
want to achieve with update and we have
a vision we just want to be like
flexible enough so the community can be
part of shaping it and what we want to
do with this update is that we want to
make Minecraft Minecraft the air
Perfect Right absolutely and we want to
do that by focusing on like certain
parts of what Minecraft is and those are
like the creativity it's like
self-expression and intrinsic motivation
so what we want to do with Minecraft we
want to inspire and enable the players
to be creative in their own ways and to
express themselves in their own like
unique beautiful ways and in this update
like one way we want to do that is to
enable self-expression through
representation and I think it's so
beautiful because you know being able to
do what you want in Minecraft is the
core of what it is so I'm really excited
that this also lets us shape it with the
community and all of you being creative
so we do have some awesome features to
show and our first guest she is here to
help us show them welcome hey
it's your first Minecraft live yes
and can you tell everyone what you do at
Mojang uh well I love to play the game
at Mojang I'm a fan uh but I'm a 3D
artist on Minecraft and you've worked on
some super cool animations for the game
everything from like really scary like
the warden yeah and really cute like the
frogs yeah oh they're so adorable yeah
they just you know their stroll is very
iconic and he's so good at it like when
for example when I see the frogs like it
really makes me feel something you're so
good at it
I'm so glad to hear it so I have a
Creator question to kick things off for
the two of you hmm
OSIS
whoa she really likes sauce and Easter
egg that we had in there indeed that's
amazing lovely and yes we are adding new
default skins and the full skills that's
like Alex and Steve so we see them as
like placeholders for the players and
our goal with Minecraft is always that
everyone should feel equally welcome in
the game and for us this is like one
step towards reaching that goal foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
lots of new default skins it's a lovely
video yes we've added seven new skins to
Minecraft uh these Skins are wonderful
collaboration within the company
um yeah we we really care about feeling
represented in Minecraft and I think
with these skins we did that
start seeing them a lot yeah yes so
and it's not only that you can play with
them in the game you will also see them
in like trailers key art merchandise so
you really get to know these skins or
like characters yeah it's it's really
beautiful because now when someone
starts the game if they haven't made a
new skin yet to like represent
themselves they also can pick one of
these and feel like it's closer to who
they are which is so awesome and these
awesome skins are coming soon they
weren't ready for live so you won't see
them in everything here but everybody's
gonna get to know them a lot and Agnes
you have something else to tell us about
oh yes there are more features and the
first one we want to show is a very
Charming Vlog called hanging signs
yes these hanging signs are super
colorful and the players can use strip
logs and change to craft them
oh we all know the sign blocks and what
they do and these hanging blocks they're
very versatile you can craft them with
every wood types and they have three
different states
oh and here you can see the different
variants so the first one here is when
you hang the hanging signs from a side
from the side of a block and this one is
like the base one so it has two chains
and it's when it hangs under a block
that's quite wide and then my favorite
you can see it has like a v-shaped chain
and this is when you hang it under
something that's narrow like under a
fence post or under Sheen that's so
pretty look they're really cool I love
how much storytelling too even from that
because adding them to different places
it's super awesome yeah we love that
when players like use these
um user blocks to do something else like
for example create like really colorful
flags with them and during our play
tests one of these like um things yeah
connect like uh to villager house
together and create these colorful yeah
Flags it's like a festival feeling
especially like I think crimson and
warped wood ones they're really quality
and Agnes you've said for a long time
that your favorite block is the sign
block yes
it's a good reason for that so A long
time ago I think maybe 12 years ago when
I played Minecraft I haven't hadn't
really found my play style yet and then
my little brother he started to play
signs on a castle he had built and he
was like this family lives here and this
is names of their family of this family
and that inspired me a lot so I started
to do that too so I started to like name
different Villages and families and like
they work with this in this house so the
sign block really inspired me to tell
stories and like build my world like do
World building with with Minecraft so I
do love signs and the hanging signs yeah
I was gonna say do you think that
hanging signs will overtake
signs for you for me a bit but what I
like with the hanging signs is that
they're a bit more expensive to craft
but I will use both okay very nice I
love that you are using them for
storytelling but also I loved your
creative use of them coloring the skies
and I can only imagine like our
community is gonna do things for this
we've never thought of they're always so
creative it's amazing yes so you have
something else to tell us about oh yes
uh we have created a beautiful new wood
set for bamboo
like with every wood set look at this
you have the planks you have fences you
have trap doors you have doors and look
look at the beautiful patterns so pretty
the patterns on the trapdoors so good
yes and I love like they're so good to
use as Windows for example
it's a really beautiful new wood set oh
it's amazing and uh one of our goals
where this would set is that we want
players to feel represented players who
grew up with bamboo in in real life and
I think that we managed to make this uh
amazing wood set very unique and
beautiful our artists did a very good
job yes definitely and you're adding a a
special block in this set only yes so
the bamboo wood sets actually have a
block that no other wood sets have and
it's called bamboo Mosaic and you can
see it here wow I think it's very
beautiful amazing I when I see this I'm
like I want to build floors with it it
wouldn't be very pretty floors I mean
they're beautiful floors and I mean it's
beautiful in the whole building and I
think what I love about this wood set is
how well it matches with other blocks
even though it feels so different too it
like looks so beautiful yeah you can
really mix it mix the blocks together
look here like with the copper and even
the Frog lights keep in the Frog lights
yeah but more than that I mean I'm very
excited because I think if you're able
to build your real world in Minecraft
like That's so exciting for people
um
yes
that it stands like on the fence post
and in the mangrove swamp yeah it's
really beautiful and you're gonna have a
boat well not exactly a boat we uh we're
gonna have a raft
yeah it works the same as a boat it also
has a chest but it looks more
adventurous
and like I love that fantasy of being
like on an adventure on the river and
then it's on a raft I think the like
storytelling and roping possibilities of
that is really lovely yeah I definitely
want to get stranded on an island make a
wrap bamboo jungle with like a panda
it's really fun I mean I think it's so
so cool to add that yes I'm ready to go
down caving like Rivers oh yes like in
the waterfalls in the caves on the left
oh that sounds fun that sounds really
fun she thank you so much for telling us
about those things
and now we have near joining us hey here
welcome back thank you thank you this
set is so amazing I know
it's turned night time yeah this is of
course I'm nice I'm just waiting for the
villagers to come out so you can trade
with them
oh Agnes is the Villager now
don't have my emeralds on me near for
those of you who don't know what do you
do at Mojang sure I'm a gameplay
designer which basically means I work on
some of the new features coming to the
game very exciting you're gonna tell us
about those but we have a Creator
question first
oh that's always hard just one she told
you well as a panda I have to say the
bamboo would set okay that's a very good
choice and what about you Agnes that's
fair I think it is a tricky question uh
I do love all of the features and
especially like how they connect
together but if I have to pick one I
actually want to pick one that we
haven't showed yet well you can do that
Agnes oh my goodness well done it's
called the shiso's bookshelves
right yeah so chisel bookshelves is the
new block that we're adding to the game
and you can interact with it to store
one to six books but it's not only books
it's also enchanted books and books and
quill so basically this is where you're
gonna store the stories of your world
and personally I'm really excited about
it because as a player I love telling
stories about my game and I used to keep
it in a physical notebook just next to
my game uh my computer but recently I
started writing it in the world sort of
storing it in chest and you know that
was actually inspired by you Agnes in
your amazing world yeah and Agnes you
like you do the coolest storytelling in
the game I I you have to tell everybody
about it because it's just it's so
in-depth I love it yes it is very nerdy
so I actually write stories both in the
game in books in game and on a notebook
outside the game and those stories are
written from different perspectives so
it's very important everything that
happens in World need to be written from
like a perspective of someone that lives
in the world so from like characters in
the world which means for example they
write like history book books and the
stories they write there they might not
even be true so they could be Legends
they could be Legends but then in the
notebook outside the game then it's my
perspective so that's like this is what
really happened I just love that I think
there's Cinder both I mean seeing like
the stories written and then being able
to pull them from the bookshelves like I
get so excited about it and these will
also have Redstone capabilities yes so
using a comparator you're actually going
to be pull a redstone signal that's
going to tell you what is the last book
that was interacted with and there's
many uses for that but personally I'm
gonna make some secret bookshelf
doorways and uh hide some something in
there what are you gonna hide
probably my Agonist poster fans
she doesn't need to know
your storytelling so how would you use
that to like tell stories the secret
place the farming opportunities to tell
stories like the first idea to just pop
up like I want to build a castle and I
want like an evil queen to live in this
castle and then she can like hide secret
things like a spiral staircase down to
like a dungeon or something like that
would be really cool I want to make an
escape room because then you're like try
and maybe
actually no I want someone in the
community to do that and then I want to
play it
I'm pretty sure you made right now yes
exactly it will be awesome and I mean
like a lot of the other things you have
this storytelling aspect but then it's
also like they're really beautiful
they're really really good to decorate
with so I love they really have like a
fantasy historical feel to them and
that's actually a field we want for all
of Minecraft and have you noticed the
top texture so you can see it like on
the floor there now it's going on to a
floor
but it was a very pretty as a floor okay
but it's very important I mean I think
that's the cool thing whenever we get
any new blocks in the game it's like
being able to use them in different ways
so you can use them as the chiseled
bookshelf or you can be like these are
the best floors you've ever seen like in
the final bookshelves and the bamboo
must say yeah exactly all the block
combinations and I'm sure the community
is going to come up with so many more
things than us amazing and you have one
more thing to tell us about yes that's
actually a feature that's quite close to
my heart because I grew up interacting a
lot with these
um so maybe it's time to take a look at
some camels
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
those are awesome tell us more about
camels yeah so like I said they're
really close to my heart because I I
remember growing up going on field trips
and sort of seeing them and riding them
and I actually have a really distinct
memory of sitting being the small kid on
this huge animal and sitting on them
went on the ground and when they gave up
the camels don't really just get up
immediately they're like indecisive
rocking back and forth sort of thing and
that was a terrifying experience as a
kid but so amazing as well and we talked
about how this update is a lot about
self-expression through representation
and I just love that so many more people
now around the world can sort of see and
experience they remember and expand from
their life in the game yeah and share it
with someone who maybe hasn't
experienced it right because that was
the thing I really loved during the
development process of camels because
you had talked so much about like your
experiences as a shy I don't know how
tall the camels is and how they stand up
in this like if we're doing okay and
then when I got to play with them in the
game I'm like it feels like you told me
about and I thought that was cool that's
really cool okay and Agnes here's a
hard-hitting question for you camels
horses why both well this is an
important question so we want to keep
update Minecraft for like a lifetime for
50 years or more and that means that
each thing we add needs to really fit
within the Minecraft ecosystem and this
is of course true for camels as well and
since camels are a writable mob and
horses are too it was very important for
us to really create a unique experience
yeah we worked quite hard on that uh
trying to find a different niche in the
game for both and may really make the
experience different and unique
um and there's many differences for
example a horse are quite agile strifing
right and left is really quick in
Minecraft and camels are quite big
animals so they're a bit slower but if
you find a a long stretch like a
straight stretch maybe a relatively flat
ground like in deserts you're you can
get quite fast actually and that's
helped by this new ability that they
have called the dash
so using the dash you can clear Ravines
or even Rivers which we all know are the
enemy of horses in Minecraft that's
pretty cool and another unique things
with the camels is that you can be two
players on it at the same time and
they're the two of you are Together
adventure into Badlands and we know that
many of our players really in the Arctic
play together with their friends so it
feels good to have a feature where you
really can go on an adventure together
yes now I'm happy that if we added it
finally my uh Agnes might invite me to
play somewhere
of course and I mean they're great for
storytelling and you have this like okay
I'm I'm taking you on an adventure come
see what I'm doing but you also you know
another side to them yeah exactly I
think that Duality is really really
interesting because like we said when
you ride with them you're with a friend
you're an adventure it's very sort of
storytelly adventury but there's another
side because you can actually Sprint
with camels and they go quite a bit
faster when you do so for example in
action scenario at night you can be out
with your friend and Agnes for example
is using the camel and moving around and
dashing out of danger and I'm with a bow
can sort of shoot an attack behind that
collaboration I think is really really
cool
and as you can see here the many mobs
can't reach us because the camera is so
tall yes
finally I get to feel how it is to be
tall
I see I know when they're not attacking
you they actually look quite cute I
think zombies
a little bit cute maybe ugly cute
yeah I mean I think that
I'm definitely gonna be the one you know
like hopefully driving the camera
I don't want to the one aiming the boat
but I do I mean it's really cool it adds
a lot especially to be able to you know
maybe you're doing a little both you're
having a nice stroll and then you're
like it turned night let's let's fight
together yeah but I mean I have to point
out that they're also just incredibly
cute
they are and especially they are ugly
cute I think therapy yeah and as we can
see we also have camel babies because
you can breed them and something pretty
interesting is that the item you're
gonna use to feed and breathe them is
actually a cactus and I thought that was
so interesting when we like researched
camels I didn't know that real world
camels eat cactus yeah I've seen many
videos of that camels eating Cactus I
thought it was really really interesting
and also Cactus is sort of an item that
doesn't have too many uses in the game
so it's always nice again being
respectful of old features sort of
adding more uses to it that's really
awesome nir thank you so much for
telling us about those amazing features
thanks for having me on October 27th
during Minecraft now you'll be able to
hear more about these cool new features
and Agnes you have one surprise for us
we do have a surprise so previous years
you have been able to play test the new
features like in many many months after
live but this year we're very excited
about this this year you will actually
be able to play Test new features in
beta's snapshots and previews used a few
days from now
[Music]
we can't wait to hear what you think
when you play test these features in a
few days like Agnes said this is the
start of features for update 1.20 and
there will be more to come throughout
the year it's almost the end of the show
and we only have the mall vote results
left but let's take a look back at
everything we announced today
[Music]
all right
[Music]
right now
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
now it's time to see who you all voted
into the game boo hello
what are you doing I'm farming but you
want the mob vote result we do I mean
the carrots are lovely wait I want to
get everybody out here
thank you so this is important because
this winning mob actually got over half
of the total votes wow okay
and the winner is
the sniffer
[Applause]
you voted and now the sniffer is coming
to the game Minecraft wouldn't be what
it is today without all of you from all
of us at Mojang Studios thank you so
much bye bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]